comme un air de déjà vu avec une
majorité de 65 députés saad hariri est
choisi comme premier ministre après des
consultations parlementaires
contraignante menée par le chef de
l'état michel aoun et lors de sa
première conférence de presse
il promet de former un gouvernement
d'experts en vue de mener des réformes
en accord avec l'initiative française
pour sortir le liban de son marasme
économique
je remercie mes collègues députés et en
particulier ceux qui m'ont fait
l'honneur de me nommer pour former un
cabinet d'experts non politiquement
aligné avec pour mission de mener des
réformes économiques financières et
administratives contenues dans la
feuille de route de l'initiative
française
[Musique]
je m'adresse aux libanais qui souffre de
difficultés au point de désespérer que
je suis déterminé à tenir la promesse
que je leur ai fait de travailler
arrêter l'effondrement de notre économie
de notre société et de notre sécurité et
à reconstruire ce qui a été détruit par
la terrible explosion du port de
beyrouth
âgé de 50 ans et héritier d'une fortune
colossale a fait son entrée sur la scène
politique malgré lui en reprenant le
flambeau de son père assassiné le 14
février 2005 dans un attentat
devenu avec le temps un acteur
incontournable de l'échiquier politique
libanais saad hariri a déjà dirigé trois
gouvernements depuis son accession au
pouvoir pour la première fois en 2009
ironie du sort le 29 octobre 2019 il ya
quasiment un an jour pour jour il
annoncé sa démission du poste de premier
ministre dans un liban en plein
soulèvement populaire contre une classe
politique accusée par sa corruption et
son incompétence d'avoir mené le pays à
sa perte des libanais pas vraiment
convaincu par cette nouvelle nomination
je suis contre cette nomination est pas
parce que c'est saad hariri
dit que chaque personne qui est nommée
pendant cette phase appartenant au
régime qui était au pouvoir sera rejetée
par le peuple que ça soit saad hariri ou
les autres le président et le chef du
parlement
il était l'enfant gâté c'est pourquoi la
révolution du 17 octobre n'acceptera pas
un homme issu de ce système
la france en pointe dans le dossier
libanais depuis la terrible double
explosion au port de beyrouth en août
dernier n'avait cessé ces dernières
semaines d'appeler la classe politique
libanaise à prendre ses responsabilités
pour éviter le chaos et la paralysie
l'échec de l'option mustapha adib le 26
septembre dernier avait provoqué l'ire
des manuels macron dénonçant la trahison
collectif des partis politiques libanais
le président français avait d'ailleurs
donné quatre à six semaines aux
responsables du pays pour former un
gouvernement de mission
un nouveau gouvernement est essentielle
pour le déblocage de plusieurs milliards
de dollars d'aidé international afin
d'aider le liban à sortir d'une crise
économique sans précédent